[Music]
in pale Hollywood news yeah submitted by
Vegas money Oh industry assistance in
Hollywood are speaking out about their
low wages Oh should that mean what the
[ __ ]
okay I needed to hear more information
I'm just judging right off the top
because I'm right judge what is your
judgment tell me if you're on the bottom
okay okay now I'm not talking about
executive assistants they have to work
their way up there they get a salary I'm
talking about
Sasa any more information but if you're
like an intern that's how you get
experience that you can then use for
leverage later to get more money but if
you're gonna complain about an
entry-level job after you applied for an
empty level job without any experience
that's where I have a problem because I
know a lot of people that do that and
I'm like [ __ ] you need to get the
experience before you can get the money
that's how it works
that's why we don't even know [ __ ] face
interns anymore oh okay all right
so this story here and there's this
hashtag that is attached to it it's
called hashtag pay up Hollywood and it's
this is like an entire effort to shed
light on where like pretty much
Hollywood assistants are saying like hey
you know what the times have changed
la is getting more expensive having a
car is more expensive don't come here
please
exactly please don't come here yeah same
but they're saying like it's just not
sustainable to be a an assistant like
entry-level assistant getting paid so
[ __ ] for an insane amount of hours so
there seem like a lot of people who are
the shot callers they they're pretty
much basing it off of their own
experience of getting into the industry
which that was like 20 years ago where
times were completely different so now
there's a lot of people saying here like
you know today's assistants are
tomorrow's writers directors execs
agents producers if they make it the
thing is - they're saying it's like this
is what's making it harder to have died
city in the industry because you in
order to get in the industry you have to
do these [ __ ] jobs but it's just getting
harder to even sustain having that [ __ ]
job to even make it up anywhere else
that's their whole point here right it's
hard getting a waitress job here what
are they talking about so when I was an
actress like and I had to be a waitress
because I wasn't making my living from
acting and you had to go apply for a
waitress job there was like 300 people
applying for a waitress job especially
if it's making good money and then if
once you get that job you're getting
paid you know like if you're at a good
restaurant then people don't want to
leave or give up their shifts cuz you
could get fired or whatever but like
that's part of the whole thing it's like
part of the filtering process then they
feel from what I get from this article
they feel like it's just not even a fair
treatment period like because once you
get a job at being a waitress and you
have certain amount of hours you get
your tips like all that like they're
getting paid for your time a fare
baseline but for assistance here they're
saying that we are just for them that
they just not even getting paid fairly
but I mean hey what's the numbers I
don't know what the numbers are but
they're just saying like here's another
benefit for them is their they get their
foot in the door of the industry like
that's the benefit you make more money
being a waitress but you're probably not
gonna get your foot in the door as
easily as being Robert Downey jr. is
assistant you know so then they're
saying that now these days you end up
having to do that job way longer which
is less sustainable to have that job
that's true because if you're a good
worker you're gonna see that in six
months there's assistants that make like
a hundred grand like cuz they're so
[ __ ] dope yeah it's hard for me to UM
empathize with the person that's writing
this or complaining about their
situation because the entertainment
industry isn't even like a real job to
begin with so for someone so why here is
you know what when I walked Jamie Foxx's
doc I don't get paid enough to do that
but if you were like a police officer a
teacher a lineman someone that fixes
electrical lines like you have a real
job that contributes to society and
you're not getting getting paid enough I
think that's a real fine
if these guys paid more but if you're
like you know every time like I take
Robert Downey jr. as close to the
drycleaner here's a pay me enough I'm
like [ __ ] you even have a real
job you're doing that so you can have
closer access to him and the reason why
they create this system like this is to
weed out the weak ass [ __ ] that
aren't gonna be able to make it that
can't handle the pressure that's the
first thing I plopped that bar for ever
like we're all lucky to be here like the
fact that even I've got to wear a real
job just playing devil's advocate right
like we're looking at it from like like
the standpoint that the person that
you're interning or assisting under is
actually being being very fair and
they're like looking for like the talent
cuz obviously I know they are but they
might be like well this person's kind of
mediocre I mean they're not costing me
much anyway so I'll just give a
regardless the industry is a fake job
you know what I mean like movement move
making movies like yeah the whole
industry is a privilege yeah the whole
that's a privilege it's not not it's not
farming you know not we're not creating
actual goods and services that are
necessary in the world for basic needs
and in society like we're just providing
energy arts entertainment is a
and it really has yeah but it's a luxury
because think about it okay like it
doesn't hit basic needs and survival
this is first world problems like if you
think about just bare bones running a
country keeping people safe keeping
people well fed bare bones right those
are the real jobs everything extra are
luxuries so we're talking from like a
middle-class mindset we're not talking
from like a third world country mindset
and and that's how I go based off of
like that global standard of like basic
needs I only say this because I got
yelled at on my podcast for saying third
world country you're supposed to call it
developing countries I don't give a [ __ ]
I didn't know that either thank you
but like cuz it's supposed to be
developed or underdeveloped or
developing kind of places bronze medals
are you know you're still placed it just
had to be more careful cuz your wife oh
absolutely
the [ __ ] I want alright so this whole
issue here it came it came from this a
prominent industry related podcast
called script notes oh I love scribe
notes so you have heard of it yeah so on
that podcast they a Chernobyl
screenwriter named Craig Mazin said in a
recent episode just because a lot of
people want these jobs doesn't mean you
can get away with paying people little
for them there's gonna be a riot and
then I says and I will just say to them
all of you who are under paying these
people you are playing with fire they
have your emails they have your
information wise up that's true if you
don't want to do the right thing because
you're a good person do the right thing
because you're a prudent person yeah cuz
we don't know how much exploitation is
going on literally the underlining thing
this whole hashtag is the exploitation
of people working these jobs is that
they're they're not getting paid
reasonable and they're not working
reasonable hours and because they're
being treated as like well why don't
they get out of the industry because
what I don't like an agency it's just
like sometimes up thing like exactly I'm
saying it's that it's just because it's
an old model does it mean like like it
should stay yeah that's not what I'm
saying I'm not fighting for the model
I'm fighting for their choices of why
they wanted to pursue this career this
industry yeah it's already not a real
industry why are they it's like what pay
me $50,000 so I can rock I don't
challenge it I thought why do we need a
change need to unionize it so like if
enough people get together and they're
like we're not being paid fairly oh
they're overworking us over the legal
amount that there's exactly where this
conversation is leading and I look
where they're gonna do like and see
these are more the executive assistants
that I'm talking about not like the I'm
a PA I'm getting everyone coffee
assistant because that's that's I was
like I need to know the information well
I think it's interesting that Craig
Mazin said something because he's a
writer and I think to your point like I
don't know that it's all like dog
walkers as much as its people of color
and women that are being hired to be
staffed in these rooms that white people
are then taking their ideas and making
million dollar shows off of and they're
getting paid okay
Oh shitty writers assistant salary and I
think maybe that's what they're touching
on it's like we're bringing you the
culture literally and you guys aren't
paying us to inform society because like
you know think of any show that has an
impact on the way yeah because when I
thought about assistant I was thinking
personal assistant yeah and I was
thinking in turn like mailroom jobs and
things like that very entry level and we
all know creative it's different though
I feel like the industry should be
changing though just because it was that
way back then I mean the exploitation
that I that I was saying like that's not
cool and yeah just because that's kind
of how it's been you know and that's how
you network and that's where you get
like the ugh you should be happy with
just doing that I'm like that's not cool
what's what people used to say about
actors like back in the day before there
was a union and all this stuff it's like
oh yeah they treat him like [ __ ] you
know they were just talking about Judy
Garland and Shirley Temple and stuff and
then they created the Union to protect
that because it wasn't just they were
used to be disposable yeah like there
were so many people that played like the
original which she caught on fire or
whatever like Wizard of Oz and they were
like just get another one
we don't care they treat up like male
porn stars which about nobody notices
and just because now we're like it's a
privilege it's like doesn't mean people
aren't passionate about it and they want
to make it a career and now like we're
in that space where it's okay to make
these things a career now yes so you
shouldn't go like get on board with that
I was wonder if it was that or like
these kids fresh out of college that are
like we should get paid and not be just
interns that's the one fish yeah those
that's a different category of people to
me it's different again when you're
talking about creative and IP and like
it's another issue but then I think
going back to what you're saying there's
so many so Hollywood Hollywood Hollywood
Hollywood isn't the only hot spot for
entertainment anymore they shoot in
Louisiana Georgia New York there's so
many places where you can go where the
cost living is so much lower so I guess
for me I'm a person of action
so before I complain I'm gonna hit up
all those cities and do all that first
before I try to completely if I run out
of if I brought all the options and I
must complain you know but I don't know
if these people have so I wanted to add
so the podcast he Craig Mazin host with
a Lenin's writer John August and so he
said that so this is what he said these
decision-makers people in the 40s and
50s are making two fundamental mistakes
first they're assuming that assistants
are pretty much exactly alike well me in
1944 I'm sorry
in 1994 white American yeah the ghost
white Americans just that out of college
with no kids and little debt who often
have parents that can help out with
expenses second these decision makers
are ignoring how much has changed since
they were assistants two decades ago a
non-exhaustive list one los angeles has
gone much more expensive a few
assistants
stay assistants longer than they used to
three owning a car still essential and
costs more for medical insurance is
pricier five short seasons make you
harder to advance and those are just
some examples like what humid it's true
though that like you talked about
Georgia and Louisiana and [ __ ] it cost
like two hundred thousand dollars to buy
a [ __ ] man
okay so are we talking about personal
assistants here cuz I don't get it I
think could be either here's my chain
why can't the assistant charge more and
it's like oh you don't want it great I'm
gonna hire some kid fresh out of college
that's that doesn't make any sense to me
only because it's difficult to find
really [ __ ] good help that you can
trust really hard to do executive [ __ ]
in your life here's that here's a tweet
says I know writers PA bringing home
about 750 a week to pay le rent plus a
car payment with no energy left to
pursue writing after 10-hour days am I
was for complaining well this was stands
for with all her fellow assistants
hashtag pay up Hollywood so that psycho
writers assistant but it seems like it's
just different kinds of assistance
throughout the industry it is true that
I think that there's a differentiation
between what la costs and what we're
paying people because in Jordan I think
you can pay minimum wage I don't know LA
and like unions because not Union actors
they'll work for free sometimes they'll
work for whatever they'll pay them [ __ ]
they'll overwork them but if you're in
the Union because usually you did a lot
of non-union work to prove that you can
act and then be in the Union then you
have a strict day rate and then as you'd
get more work that rate changes and like
they acknowledge that they need a skill
I'd be for that assistance guild Union
unionize
[Music]